ALLIES.
MORE THAN 15,000 STILL THERE AT
LAST CHECK.
NAT
NATASHA BERTRAND, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
AND THOSE AFGHAN CIVILIANS ARE
IN MORE DANGER THAN EVER.
OPERATION ALLIES REFUGE IS THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN TO
AIRLIFT SOME 20,000 AFGHAN
INTERPRETERS TO SAFETY.
SO FAR THE U.S. HAS MANAGED TO
RESCUE AROUND 1,000 AND THAT
LEAVES 1,000 MORE PEOPLE AND
THEIR FAMILIES STUCK IN THE
CROSS HAIRS.
RUHEME WAS ONE OF THOSE AFGHAN
INTERPRETERS.
HE KNEW DANGER CAME WITH THE JOB
AND HE'S BEEN TRYING TO GET HIS
WIFE AND FIVE KIDS TO SAFETY FOR
YEARS.
BUT HE'S HAD AN EVEN BIGGER
TARGET ON HIS BACK EVER SINCE
U.S. TROOPS STARTED TO WITHDRAW.
ENTER RETIRED U.S. ARMY SERGEANT
GERALD KING.
THEY BECAME FAST FRIENDS AFTER
MEETING ON THE SAME U.S. ARMY
POST IN 2016.
THIS WEEK RAHEME AND HIS FAMILY
FINALLY FOUND SAFE PASSAGE TO
CANADA.
THEY GOAL IS NOW IS TO LIVE AND
WORK HERE AND GET CLOSER TO
THEIR PARENTS.
THEY'RE WITH US NOW.
THIS IS SUCH A GOOD NEWS STORY.
GREAT TO SEE YOU BOTH.
GERALD, LET'S START WITH YOU.
JUST TELL US ABOUT THE
RELATIONSHIP YOU DEVELOPED
OVERSEAS WITH RAHEEM AND THE
REACTION FROM FINDING OUT HE'S
GOING TO GET OUT OF HARMS WAY.
>> YES, THANK YOU, PAMELA, AND
CNN FOR HAVING US ON AND SHARING
OUR STORY.
AND I HAVE TO SAY HELLO TO
RAHEEM AND -- WHO ARE WATCHING
NOW IN TORONTO, CANADA.
HE HAS FOUND PAS MG THROUGH THE
CANADIAN SIV PROGRAM.
LAST SUNDAY HE LANDED IN
TORONTO.
AND IS QUARANTINED NOW AT THE
HOTEL IN TORONTO.
SO WE ARE PLANNING ON A VISIT
NEXT SUNDAY ONCE HE COMPLETES
HIS QUARANTINE TIME LINE,
TWO-WEEK QUARANTINE.
>> IF YOU WOULD, HELP US
UNDERSTAND, GERALD, THE BOND YOU
DEVELOPED WITH HIM.
THERE'S SO MUCH TALK ABOUT THESE
THOUSANDS OF AFGHAN ALLIES THAT
ARE LEFT IN AFGHANISTAN RIGHT
NOW THE U.S. IS TRYING TO
EVACUATE.
TELL US WHY IT MEANT SO MUCH TO
YOU TO GET RAHEEM AND HIS FAMILY
OUT OF THERE.
>> SURE.
HE -- RAHEEM AND I WORKED
TOGETHER AND HE WAS MY
INTERPRETER AT MY FORWARD
OPERATING BASE NEAR GARDEZ.
AND THE MORE WE WORKED TOGETHER
AND THE MORE WE SHARED AND THE
DANGER THAT WE SHARED AND THE
GOOD TIMES TOGETHER, WE BECAME
CLOSER.
HE'S THE SAME AGE AS MY YOUNGEST
SON, SO I TOOK THAT CONNECTION
TO HIM VERY STRONGLY AND VERY
EARLY IN OUR RELATIONSHIP AND
HELPED HIM AND HIS WIFE, AND
THEY HAD THREE CHILDREN AT THE
TIME.
I'VE JUST PICTURED MY SON
RAISING THREE CHILDREN IN THAT
ENVIRONMENT, AND IT JUST -- I
COULDN'T IMAGINE THAT.
SO WE ARE HALFWAY HOME AT THIS
TIME.
WE STILL NEED SUPPORT FROM
TORONTO TO THE U.S. SIV PROGRAM.
IF WE WERE WAITING ON THE U.S.
SIV PROGRAM, HE WOULD STILL BE
STUCK IN KABUL.
SO MY THANKS AND MY GRATITUDE AS
TO CANADIAN SIV PROGRAM WHO'S
BROUGHT THIS FORWARD AND GOT HIM
TO SAFETY AS FAST AS THEY DID.
SO I HOPE THIS IS A CONTINUATION
TO THE U.S. AND NOT A
DESTINATION.
>> HOPEFULLY SO SO YOU CAN BE
REUNITED.
YOU ARE HIS FAMILY.
THIS IS SUCH A TOUCHING STORY.
TELL US HOW YOU'VE BEEN SPORTING
HIM OVER THE YEARS AND HELP HIS
FAMILY MANAGE TO GET TO CANADA?
>> WELL, OVER THE YEARS OUR
RELATIONSHIP HAS DEVELOPED, AND
IT'S GROWN AND BECOME REALLY
RICH AND FULL NOW.
THEY -- RAHEEM AND HIS WIFE CALL
US MOMMY AND PAPA, AND THAT IS
WHAT WE ARE TO THEM.
WHEN WE KNEW THEY'D BE LEAVING
FOR KABUL, WE SPOKE PERSONALLY
WITH HIS MOM AND DAD.
AND HIS MOM SAID TO ME, I AM
GIVING MY SON TO YOU, YOU ARE
NOW HIS MOTHER AND I ENTRUST HIM
TO YOU.
THE KIDS CALL US GRANDMA AND
PAPA, AND WE JUST LOVE THEM.
AND WE SPEAK -- NOW WE'RE
TALKING EVERY DAY BECAUSE WE'RE
ON THE SAME TIME ZONE.
BEFORE THAT IT WOULD BE TEXTS
AND E-MAILS.
AND BEFORE NOW WE WERE JUST
WORKING SO HARD THROUGH THE SIV
PROGRAM.
WE WERE LUCKY TO HAVE SUPPORT
THROUGH THE ALLIANCE OF WARTIME
ALLIES, AN AMAZING ORGANIZATION
THAT IS FIGHTING EVERY DAY TO
GET THESE 18,000 PEOPLE OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN WHO HAVE SUPPORTED
THE UNITED STATES.
AND WE ARE JUST, AGAIN, HOPING
THAT WITH EVERYTHING THAT IS
GOING ON RIGHT NOW THAT WE CAN
HELP THEM FIND A WAY TO MOVE
THEIR APPLICATION THAT HAS
ALREADY BEEN VETTED THROUGH
CANADA OVER TO THE UNITED STATES
SYSTEM WHERE IT'S BEEN FOR FIVE
YEARS AND GET THEM HOME TO US.
>> AND JUST TO REALLY SET THE
STAGE HERE, GERALD, OF THE
DANGER THAT RAHEEM AND HIS
FAMILY WERE FACING BEFORE THEY
WERE FORTUNATELY SAFELY
EVACUATED TO CANADA.
HELP US UNDERSTAND THAT DANGER.
>> THAT DANGER STARTED IN HIS
VILLAGE OUTSIDE OF DGARDEZ.
WE KNEW THAT THIS TALIBAN WAS
TAKING OVER APPROXIMATELY A
MONTH AGO, SIX WEEKS AGO.
AND WE MADE A DECISION AS HIM
AND I TALKED TO MOVE HIM TO
KABUL BECAUSE IT GOT TOO
DANGEROUS DOWN THERE.
AND THE TARGET ON HIS BACK WAS
GETTING BIGGER.
SO WE HAD TO PICK UP HIM AND HIS
FAMILY, MOVE HIM TO KABUL, AND
HE WAS IN A SAFE HOTEL AT THAT
TIME.
AND AS YOU KNOW TODAY GARDEZ --
GARDEZ FELL TODAY I BELIEVE.
SO IT IS REALLY BAD DOWN THERE.
HE STILL HAS FAMILY LEFT THERE.
AT THIS TIME HE HAS CONTACT WITH
HIS FAMILY, AND THEY ARE SAFE AT
THIS TIME, BUT THEY WERE IN
KABUL HOTEL FOR APPROXIMATELY
TEN DAYS BEFORE THE CANADIAN
EMBASSY CONTACTED THEM AND FLEW
THEM TO TORONTO.
>> AND WE KNOW RIGHT NOW KABUL
IS SURROUNDED BY THE TALIBAN.
IT'S BEEN A LONG ROAD.
>> CORRECT.
THE ROAD BETWEEN GARDEZ AND
KABUL HAD CHECKPOINTS ON IT WITH
THE TALIBAN.
AND ALSO THE TALIBAN HAS
SIGNIFICANT BIOMETRICS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THEY GOT THAT
INFORMATION OR TECHNOLOGY, BUT
THEY HAVE BIOMETRICS AND THAT'S
WHAT SCARED HIM THE MOST OF
BEING STOPPED BY THE TALIBAN
WITH THE U.S. PAPERS AND THE
BIOMETRIC SYSTEM IN PLACE.
>> YEAH, THE BIOMETRICS TO BE
ABLE TO IDENTIFY THOSE WHO
HELPED THE U.S.
>> CORRECT.
>> FINALLY, GERALD, WHAT ARE
YOUR THOUGHTS AS A RETIRED
SOLDIER WHO FOUGHT IN
AFGHANISTAN ON THE TROOP
WITHDRAWAL?
>> I KNEW THAT THIS TIME WOULD
COME, AND WE TRAINED THE AFGHAN
ARMY THE BEST WE COULD FOR 20
YEARS.
I GOT IT.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S LONG
ENOUGH OR IT WASN'T TOO LONG.
I'M NOT IN A POSITION TO MAKE
THAT DETERMINATION.
BUT WE TRAINED THEM TO STAND UP
AND FIGHT FOR THEIR COUNTRY AND
LEFT THEM THE EQUIPMENT THAT
THEY NEEDED.
BUT THE PULL OUT IS WHAT I HAVE
A PROBLEM WITH.
WE SHOULD NOT HAVE TO SEND
SOLDIERS BACK IN TO DO THIS JOB
THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN DONE
BEFORE THEY CLOSED BAGRAM
AIRFIELD.
THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN THE LAST
THING TO CLOSE IN MY OPINION,
BUT NOW WE'VE GOT TO SEND
SOLDIERS BACK IN HARMS WAY TO
HELP EVACUATE THE EMBASSIES AND
THESE INTERPRETERS WHO FOUGHT
SIDE BY SIDE WITH US EVERY DAY.
AND WE LEFT THEM THERE, AND THE
WORLD IS WATCHING.
THE WORLD IS WATCHING US EVERY
MOVE AS THIS THING, THIS
SITUATION COMPOUNDS HOURLY.
IT CHANGES HOURLY.
SO I JUST HAVE A DISAGREEMENT OR
A HEARTBURN ON HOW WE DID IT.
I'M NOT SURE I AGREE ON THE TIME
LINE OF WHEN WE DID IT.
THE AFGHAN PEOPLE HAVE GOT TO
STAND UP AND FIGHT FOR THEIR
COUNTRY.
>> GERALD, THANK YOU NOT JUST
FOR COMING ON BUT FOR ALL YOUR
SERVICE AND FOR FIGHTING FOR
THIS COUNTRY AND MAKING ALL THE
SACRIFICES YOU DID.
AND LYNNETTE, THANK YOU FOR ALL
THE SACRIFICES YOU HAVE MADE AS
WELL IN SUPPORT OF YOUR HUSBAND.
I KNOW MILITARY FAMILIES GO
THROUGH A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT, AND
I'M SO GLAD THAT THIS HAS A
HAPPY ENDING.
AND WE HOPE THAT HE COMES BACK
AND WILL